hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the quarterfinals of the 2022
fide grand prix it's andreas penco vs
hikaru nakamura and this game is just
brilliant it has it all it has so many
missed opportunities that you will
you're simply not going to believe that
this actually happened uh so without
further ado let's check it out there is
quite a lot to cover and enjoy uh so
isibenko with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 by hikaru
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
c4 hikaru goes for bishop to c5 he goes
for the joko piano game and now d3 the
joko pianissimo and not going for the
evans gambit unfortunately but don't
worry it's still a great game
knight to f6 and now a4 so this is all
very standard stuff with a6 castles by
white and now d6 we have a5 grabbing
more space on the queen side and now
usually black will play h6 here but
hikaru goes bishop back to a7 right away
and it is now as of move seven that we
have a completely new game uh so c3 base
panko uh with some ideas of b4 d4 is
also possible in the future we have
castles and h3 now taking away the g4
square from black's pieces h6 and now
bishop to e3 so these are all very very
useful uh joko piano moves uh attacking
the bishop on e7 so here just rook e8
black doesn't really care and queen to
b3 since the rook just moved we
developed the queen with uh tempo as the
the f7 pawn is now hanging so queen to
e7 guarding the f7 pawn and now knight b
to d2 we have rook to b8
and now bishop captures an a7 and
already
there is one thing that you can notice
in this position and it's a very
important um a little detail
it's that black's rooks are not
connected and that's going to mean a lot
here bishop captures any a7
knight captures an a7 and now espeno
strikes in the center with uh with the
d4 saying that uh okay you could capture
here but uh what does this um do for you
well that's that's kind of the thing you
have to play this e captures on e4 and
now if c captures on d4 we just continue
bishop to d7 of course uh you don't
capture on e4 then knight captures an e4
and after something like queen captures
on e4 the the f7 pawn is left unguarded
the problem is after this d4 move hikaru
did not capture on d4 he car just
brought the knight back into the game
with knight to c6 now put more pressure
here
but now the position is uh well lost for
hikaru so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this incredible win
already on move 14 while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on remembering what
we mentioned and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show uh it is uh
d5 yes the rooks are not connected and
that's all there is to it so once the
night moves uh doesn't really matter
where to the a7 we're just going to play
bishop captures on a6 and now
the pawn cannot capture as the rook on
b8 is undefended so we're going to
capture it so what what black can play
is bishop captures an h3 so you also
grab a pawn and you connect your rooks
but now we play bishop captures on b7
and now we've created a past a pawn and
this is quite enough for white bishop if
bishop g4 we're gonna play knight to h2
attack the bishop and the ones bishop to
e2 comes attacking the rook and yes now
black is threatening bishop to a6 to go
after the bishop since the bishop can't
really move it's still on the same file
as the queen but now we simply give up
the rook we play a6 and we already have
a monster pass pawn on a6 black will
capture here of course we're gonna
capture on f1 and white is much much
better here so this is what both of them
missed
well hikaru just missed it and denis
panko did not think that hikaru would
miss something like this and then he
missed it as well but uh always
remember this uh it's a very basic
principle if your opponent's rooks are
disconnected that can always mean
something like in this case that the
rook on b8 is undefended but okay after
knight to c6 is pink who just played
rook after e1 and now hikaru quickly
developed the bishop with bishop to d7
uh acipenko does push d5 now although
now it's not as impressive knight to a7
and now bishop back to f1 uh we have
knights the h7 hikar now ready to strike
with f5 and now c for strengthening the
center we have knights the g5 offering a
trade of knights and here just queen to
e3 uh putting more pressure here but
really going for that knight on a7 so
knight captures on f3 with check knight
captures and now knight the c8 so still
not a lot of squares for this knight
again the rooks are disconnected um not
not a pleasant position for hikaru and
here we have b4 now with ideas of b5 5
and creating some past pawns in the
future
hikaru strikes with f5 he doesn't want
to wait um and see
what happens on the queen side and now
bishop to d3 again the position is very
delicate and i will show one line that's
really really awesome for white but you
have to really really um
uh you know uh see into the future to go
for this b5 and now after f captures an
e4 we just play knight d2 we're going to
recapture the pawn not a lot of
and not a lot of black can do about this
and there really isn't a good move for
black here that's the whole point after
black makes a move we're going to
capture on e4 and after black makes
another move we're going to capture on
a6 and now after black recaptures we
push c5 yeah and now our position is
just incredible uh the a6 pawn is also
hanging so first bishop to b5 let's say
we block this rook e to b1 and now d
captures on c5 we're going to play
bishop captures on b5 and after a
captures queen captures on c5 and again
white has his uh past a pawn and
enjoys a well pretty much a winning
position so b5 uh also very very nice
here but okay bishop to d3 first and now
he just defends on f5 so queen to f6 e
captures on f5 with bishop captures and
f5 bishop captures and queen captures on
f5 so now
knight the d4 another very nice trick
and another one made possible uh simply
because the rooks are not connected so
you can't capture here because the rook
is hanging so queen back to f7 but it
doesn't help all that much uh since you
still can't capture we're still winning
the exchange and now yes bingo could
just bring the knights to the e6 and
it's a perfectly fine plan but he
strikes with f4 and this is also very
very impressive uh but uh hikaru has one
move that saves the game for him so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this brilliant defensive idea for hikaru
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on defending a
seemingly uh indefensible position and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course knight to b6
that's the good stuff uh you offer the
the knight here and all of this just to
connect your rook so now your rooks are
connected and now this is a threat so
you you know uh
a lot of stuff was missed in this game
because the rooks were not connected and
because of the inability to actually
connect to them but okay here for
example a capture sun on b6 e captures
on the e4 now opening an attack on the
queen and after queen captures here now
just c captures on b6 and now you say
okay if you capture here i'm gonna
capture on f4 so after white makes a
move we're just gonna trade here
captures captures and i'll play rook to
f8 and black's position is just great
nothing to worry about here
but hikaru missed this he played c6
which is not a bad move is just not as
good as knight to the b6 and now yes
panko is once again winning so f
captures on e5
and he did spend some 20 minutes on this
move maybe even a little bit more the
problem is is pinko is now down to eight
minutes where asikow has some 20 minutes
on the clock and here we have c captures
on d5 again hikaru goes for not the
greatest of moves but maybe the most
complicated one because if if you just
recapture
uh then we get knights to e6 and after
knight to d6 black finally gets to
develop his knight now we can play rook
eight to c1 defend the pawn now black
will defend his pawn uh we will now
advance it over to e4 so the knight
defends it but now queen to g3 attack
the knight and once the queen defends
this we can even play knight captures on
g7 and even this is perfectly fine if
queen captures queen captures here and
now the black king is completely uh
shattered well uh no defense is left and
well we we will have a past deep on so
that's also great
so instead after f captures on e5 he
carplayed c captures on d5 and now uh
well now is panko plays e6 and again
it's not a bad move it's just that there
was a a trickier one queen to g3 is much
much scarier because you're now
threatening to play e characters on d6
this will be a pass pawn and then you
will just solidify with c5 you will have
a defended pass pawn on d6 and now if d
captures an e5 we can just trade rook
captures queen captures rook captures
your rook is again hanging and once you
move this rook really isn't anything
better just a rook f1 you attack the
queen and now it doesn't matter what
black plays for example queen d7 knights
to f5 and everything is just working
nice for for white if d captures on c4
you can even play knight captures on g7
because the rook is simply not in the
game if queen captures we're gonna play
queen here check king here rook to f7
win the queen and so on so
that's what's in the position but okay
e6 was played and okay who wouldn't play
this it's uh advancing your pawn to e6
you are ready to solidify with c
captures on d5 so queen to g6 by hikaru
and now not c captures on the e5 even
though this is by far the best for white
if we if we do this uh then we are just
um
incredible even after knight e7 we can
give up the pawn or rather we have to
give up the pawn we're going to play
rook eight to c1 prepare to leave the
rook to c7 knight captures attacks the
queen queen f3 attacks the knight and
once the knight moves rook to c7 so
that's how you you play this it's not
easy to spot but it's very very
difficult to defend the rook can come to
f7 in the future you're also putting
pressure on on the b7 pawn
so really uh hard for black to play if
rook to f8 queen e2 the pawn is always
nicely defended and well it it is just
better for white but uh in the game rook
to f1 was played yes pinko really wants
to rush with this rook to f7 idea
and now hikaru goes knight to e7 again
we have to show the lines because
they're super super exciting but here
black really should capture uh as white
allowed it you should capture this and
now it's not that you're just up
material you your fast pawn is already
on c4 if rook to f7 you can just play
knight e7 uh rook a to f1 and it's
perfectly fine white doesn't have uh
anything here it
black can hold this so instead after
rook f1 hikaru played 97 right away he
really wants to connect those rooks but
now rook to f7
uh we have d captures on c4 now it's
perfectly fine again to capture the pawn
rook a to f1 and now hikaru just plays a
king the h8 um uh
king to h8 getting ready to
uh well
either block some checks with knights
the g8 or uh not be so close to the
action uh even though uh queen to g5 is
also possible you offer a queen trade
and then you you play on but hikaru
needs to complicate things he plays king
to h8 and now we have rook one to f3 uh
the problem is uh here is panko was
extremely low on the clock he was down
to some 25 minutes when he played this
and this is only moved 32 he still needs
to make eight more moves to reach time
control and now he carl plays knight to
c6 again knight to d5 is what you have
to play here you attack the queen and
once the queen moves you play queen to
e4 and it looks very tricky because
white can just attack the g7 square but
you play rogue g8 that's how you defend
if through g4 you attack the queen queen
e3
you force a queen trade and everything
is okay but hikaru played knights to c6
and now izupinko is winning once again
and he goes for knight captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now e7 and look at
this it's game over how do you defend
this rook to rook to f8 is coming so
hikaru quickly hides the king we have
king to h7
and now queen to f4 we need to guard
that g3 square to play rook to g3 and
finally win this game
and if you try something like queen g5
to go for a for a quick queen trade rook
g3 still wins uh we can sacrifice the
queen and just checkmate the black king
king g8 and now rook to g7 will be
checkmate as the pawn covers the f8
square so hikaru of course uh spots this
in in an instant he plays rook to g8 and
it's still uh winning for white but now
uh white just uh why'd you just capture
on c4 and claim that his position is
much better and slow play this even
though you only have a few seconds on
the clock but you do have some uh
increments so uh capturing and c4 was
the way to go but okay he's now still in
the attack he plays queen rook to g3
attacks the queen queen to e6 and now
rook to e3 he repeats uh
wants to grab some more time on the
clock and now he doesn't repeat again
now he plays rook to f8 uh he offers a
trade of brooks and also just uh well
that pawn is now defended from from all
the sides uh but now comes rook to e8 he
car just blocks the pawn we have rook
captures on g8 king captures and queen
captures on c4 with check and now he
carries blocks with queen to f7 and
another very tricky position where uh
it's perfectly fine for white but you
have to play queen to e6 uh point is
that after queen capture so you're going
to play rook captures and now after king
f7 going after the pawn you're going to
start gobbling up pawns rook captures on
e6 king captures or or even
rook captures or king captures through
captures on c6 and now after rook to b8
you can even go rook to g7 go after this
pawn with check and now if king goes
back to defended now the king is very
far away now you play rook to b6 and you
are again winning with white so
that's what you have to play but yes
pencil played queen captures on a6 he
says all right this has to be winning i
i'm sure of this uh so he car plays rook
captures on e7 rook captures queen
captures and now the
final mistake of the game queen captures
on c6 and again who wouldn't play this
you uh create another passport now you
have two connected passports on the
queen side and this must be winning and
not only that you're up upon but queen
end games are tricky like this i will
show you a win uh and it's uh well when
you once you see it of course it um
makes sense but queen to c8 check king
to h7 or king to f7 for that matter but
after i came to f7 we just pick up this
pawn and then it's perfectly fine
because the black king is now also wide
in the open but point is after king to
h7 now we play queen to f5 check and
after king to g8 queen f2 uh we uh
prevent
any and all checks from black and now
we're just gonna play a6 a7 our queen
guards the a7 square uh then we can play
queen b6 queen b8 and win the game this
way but this is this is what's needed to
win the game however after a queen
captures an e7 uh yes pink will play the
queen captures on c6 and now hikaru is
uh
on the checking side so queenie one
check king h2 queen captures on b4 and
now queen d5 check king h8 queen to
eight you putting the queen behind the
pass pawn but hikaru is uh more than uh
more than fast enough to stop the pawn
queen f4 check g3 queen to d4 keeping an
eye on the a7 square we have a6
and now comes uh queen to a7 just
blocking this pawn
we have h4
and now uh just a d5 starting to push
that pawn queen to e2 and now queen to
d4 so there's no way for white to make
progress queen back to a2 queen back to
a7 queen uh king to g2 was played now
comes d4 hikar also starts pushing his
pass pawn queen e2 now queen to d7 queen
to e4 and now d3 so now both players uh
will get a queen b a queen b7 queen to
d8 a7 and d2 we have a8 queen d1 queen
now there are four queens on the board
and here the espanka played queen
captures on the e8 and he was in this
position on move 58 that the players
agreed to a draw as once the
uh queen captures queen on the eight
it's a completely equal material with uh
no imbalance in the position whatsoever
this is a draw so of course after the
queen captures queen players agree to a
draw and this means that hikaru is the
winner of the group is pengo could have
done it
but this just wasn't his game i mean
this wasn't hikaru's game but
it also wasn't the espanko's game there
were so many
so many positions where you could have
one and especially that uh that one in
in the beginning of the game on move 14
where hikaru just retreated with knight
to c6 finding this d5 move followed by
bishop captures on a6
uh beautiful stuff
but yeah chess is like that and uh you
know just because it's not your
opponent's day doesn't mean it's your
day
so yeah that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it and uh well as always feel
free to suggest more nice games from the
fide grand prix uh i would like to thank
mr hoody guy uh sorry hit the hoodie
knight uh god for making me an atheist
john anderson uh sorry about that in
this position feel free to pause the
video and jonathan kemp for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the video grand prix until it ends
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day